tutti ragazzi perché questo video sono
fa vj e oggi siamo su ben mm ben capito
cosa si debba fare per figo perché ho
visto alcuni screenshot queste ben vive
in un mondo di merda
anche noi vedo che ben il mio stesso
parrucchiere è fantastico un giorno ben
trova ed il primo non morta è un morto
d'oro diventarono amici che bello mi
sembra proprio un ottima amicizia hans
shout master che benché la barba li ha
presi gli parli a fatti prendere
perfetto li ha catturati per usarli per
il più grande somma il creato che cosa
vuol dire che figo quindi è uno show c'è
nel senso io sono io chi sono
giorno a io sono ed space per saltare a
sistemi sta spiegando i comandi non
averlo avevo capito ma posso annunciare
la mia la mia testa fantastico bello ciò
la mira ragazzina milan e corpo so
continuare a rotolare con la testa 10 su
10 come cazzo ci torno a ok fi lanciare
la mia testa perché grazie
siamo ragazzi iran dei premi e per
intere ok
beh non è non è così difficile senso
forse più difficile leder schuh begin ci
sta guardando tifo trono sciora
guardandoti potabili d'abito
grazie grazie inchino al pubblico allora
guarda le video camere di grazie grazie
grazie
effetto ago ione guarda che non devi e
vitali citare il pubblico davanti a me
perché tutte meno e non ci arriva la
nota bene che fanno qualche cazzo fa il
mio corpo si è partiti ragazzi devo
correre quindi corro devo e tv takeshi's
castle non solo gli zombie che ci passa
al pelo ragazzi fantastico ma tra
l'altro al cappellino di natale perché
natale o cela di fisso che per culo io
quindi devo saltare le cose senza farmi
colpire e ce la sto anche facendo un
fenomeno non sapevo potessi rotolare
fantastico io sono un non morto che
continueranno a morire e geniale e
geniale ed è assurdo ragazzi stupendi
figlia che svetta in faccia sarebbe
figlio fare uno show del genere se
esistessero i non morti sono ancora in
piedi sono ancora c'è il mio corpo
perfetto perfetto non al braccio ma chi
ha bisogno del braccio bravo zio corri
parla mamma sony tv ma guardava ma cosa
sa bravo guardava ma senza gambe senza
niente senza sono vivo oddio ma chi ha
bisogno di gambe geniale è la minchia
qualcuno prende la testa dal pubblico
ora che vale i soldi ma in tutto questo
ben dove sta cioè non ho capito bene
qual è l'obiettivo
cosa fa ben ragazzi chi ha bisogno delle
gambe non servono a niente inutili a
volerlo posso lanciare la testa sul
check point ecco ben sei tu e mio amico
no devo salvare non lo posso salvare non
ci arriverò mai a ben è impossibile la
ragazza è bellissimo ma basta terzo
subito ai vai vai vai vai vai vai
partenza da dio anno possono fare
programmi nei generi
grande fratello tipo no una gamba
ragazzo non corona e vabbè testa ancora
c'è la pista ancora c'è perfetta
continua con una gamba è bellissimo vai
vai vai vai
ok riesco anche a rotolare senza una
gamba ce ragazzi qua progaming serie a
proprio laggiù un genio grazie a sono
esplosivisti folli per qualche motivo
rise and rise and rise all è bellissimo
ma vivo piedi soldati in piedi in piedi
che culo
non so come e intanto sono morto di
nuovo non so come son passato ragazzino
non mi fate domande effetto perfetto
come non diamo alla fine più verità non
ci credo non ci credo
noi sa cosa ho fatto per mi fermi per
doria fervido arrivare alla fine così ma
serio se non sono riuscito a vincere
così sono saltato su il cameraman forme
che come è possibile giuro che non
volevo provare lo fa un'altra rola prove
va bene anche così organizzati
importante non perdere la testa nel
senso perché sei diventato famoso perché
chi diventa famoso così e perde la testa
zio cercato pian piano è diventata
difficile senza ragazzi e volte sega
logo sparare stanno aprendo i premi ben
premi ben ce l'ha ben fare bene non
serve a niente in sto gioco inutile
stupid backstage andrebbe sense ui die
la mia paga da artista professionista 12
mar giallo già lo facevo e non è che è
rimasta in piazzata la tavola al piede
l'importante ragazzi arrivare alla fine
poi fate sega di come perché quando
mettiamo lo stiamo andando
ma io scusate non ho il corpo potete da
chi è questo c'è un tizio a zio e non ho
il corpo mi va bene
stufi o della [ __ ]
lei è un pen ribadì loves clouds vale ma
la riga tanto però la holding andiamo il
caricamento ci siamo ragazzi ancora così
intimo ero così a vita ci sono ormai ho
solo la testa e rimango roses è partita
di brutto la musica a caso ma è un boss
ma ci sono anche i boss ragazzi ci sono
anche bossi il suo gioco fermi tutti
addio e non solo per un fenomeno io nego
batteri vostre prove dice di quanto non
lo sapremo mai perché sono morto un
[ __ ] vallo ragazzi facciamo il bossi
che siamo alla fine può farcela anche se
sembra impossibile devo prendere i
cannoni aver fin qua ci arriva uno che
faccio mi sparo proprio di contro bossi
l'ho fatta se è il primo ce l'abbiamo
chi secondo ball merchandising di
magliette di di ed è maestra vendono più
di star wars bello hai superato appieno
l'ostacolo zio credimi cos'è un
movimento neonazista mi sono salvato per
purissimo sono morto come un deficiente
ma solo per vieri che culo ragazzi ce
n'è ancora uno non ci arriverò mai nella
vita ma va bene ma tom e va bene anche
neanche la possibilità di saltare
arato di brutto cos'è no no ero arrivato
ero arrivato né dal cannone non ci credo
sì ci siamo ci siamo
oddio ti ringrazio ci ho messo anni non
riesco in modo manco a messa o di non
averlo colpito da ben prendi la mia
testa è la falsa fantastico ragazzi è
stata è stato difficile ma veramente
tanto per restare un boss di un gioco
indie e stato difficilissimo lavoro
ragazzi conti parole pro semplice questa
mi sembra un po più incasinata è più
horror e la proverò nel prossimo
episodio che lo faccio indipendentemente
da quello che chiedete perché sto gioco
è troppo figo field ragazzi spero io mi
sento così generoso l'argomento era mi
piace al capace di facebook e con il
dotata l'estinzione fare l'inchino
staccandomi la testa ma non c'è un check
point senza vestiti iscritti ci vediamo
emozioni dei ragazzi
[Musica]